but on top of that
um
we are respecting the pronouns and
self-identification
of a child rapist who raped and sexually
tortured their their his own child
from the daily mail there's a tren now i
want you to
i'm going to read
this article
as it was written
okay because this that's
really the main point i want to make
about this is the way that this is
written okay
from a daily mail it says a transgender
mother
who forced the seven-year-old daughter
she fathered to engage in child
pornography at her new jersey home has
been jailed for 25 years without parole
along with three accomplices
um
marina vols previously named matthew was
sentenced on friday alongside another
transgender woman ashley romero
previously named adam and two other
offenders sean allen and uh dulcina
neko 21 vols 32 rand ran a quote family
owned transgender pornography production
studio
specializing in amateur bdsm and taboo
fetish content
from her home in franklin township
um
and
it goes further into the details which
i'm not even going to read because it's
totally horrifying i mean what they did
to this child is just beyond
description and the fact that we're
i mean 25 years in jail for
sexually torturing your child is
that's a slap on the wrist i mean you
might as well give him
you might as well just put him in county
lock up for for a day
in comparison to what the penalty ought
to be
i mean just think about that you in the
united states of america this is someone
sexually torturing
and exploiting their own child
and they're going to see the outside of
a jail cell
in fact he's going to be you know 25
years
they say without the possibility of
parole we'll see about that
even if he spends every day of that in
jail
um you know he'll be out by the age of
uh late 50s early 60s
no this should be
you're
convicted of it
and then the very next day we
you know take you up to the uh to the
gallows and we take care of the problem
public execution would be really the
best solution here for somebody like
that
but on top of that um
we are respecting the pronouns and
self-identification
of a child rapist who raped and sexually
tortured their their his own child
and that's how we end up with a with a
phrase like
she
fathered
which would be bad enough
being as it's completely incoherent
but we're finding that phrase in this
article about this person
because we're afraid about we're afraid
of hurting his feelings
raped and sexually abused his own child
and we're afraid that if he sees the
daily mail article his feelings will be
hurt
[Music]
total total uh moral insanity
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated